what's your role here at Khan Academy
it's a developer on the data science
team so I work with a lot of the rest of
the development team and the rest of the
data science team to look at questions
like how do we get people learning new
content as quickly as possible so that
we can get them learning new things but
not overwhelming them with things that
are too difficult I've also done things
like working on the learns from team and
making the leaderboards and doing the
data analysis and software development
that we need to get and so I'm kind of
the getting people to learn at a optimal
speed or optimal quickness how is that
related to data in this but you know
especially for people who think Khan
Academy is a there's a bunch of videos
if some exercise
how does data help people learn as
quickly as possible so one thing that we
can look at is one thing we were looking
at was how long does it take people to
come to complete missions and if we see
that there are admissions are kind of
the the personalized guided exercises on
Khan Academy shinzo the personalized
path through the content and Khan
Academy and so we can look at us we can
look at among all people who are doing
missions what did their problem history
of life like what problems have they
done did they get them correct correct
does it seem like her just doing an
extraordinarily large number of problems
to look easy each of them does it seem
like they're just getting every problem
wrong and we need to figure out some way
to for something different contents and
so we can look at people's paths through
these various missions and then see well
what are the sorts of things that we
should tweak to maybe say you're on a
path that we can give people an
accelerated way through a mission or
where do we maybe need to add more
content or figure out how to redirect
people into a different mission path for
things like and what does that look like
on a day to day basis I mean you know
how much of it is kind of kind of
science how much of it is kind of
software engineering how much is it kind
of kind of a more business side you know
talking to the team and or outside folks
to figure out what to do I think it kind
of CAD aamir pretty unique in that it is
I'm assuming that we actually do a lot
of engineering and a lot of that I think
is because where we're working with data
that we often don't know how to make
sense of so what we need to do is try
things so we can use our intuition to
make the best yes about what we think
will help people's learning and then we
design a test among a small number of
users to see is this really in fact
increasing their learning and then make
sure before we were all about to
everyone so we have a very sort of
empirical engineering approach to doing
this
where isn't a lot of other organizations
you might see something more like we're
gonna make complicated models of our
data and go with that but I don't think
we know how to make complicated models
of our particular sort of data yet but
of course we're looking at and how does
it how does it reflect it in your day to
day like what do you wake up in the war
and you know what's your days like or
your average day my average day I
probably spend most of my time doing
software development and then some of my
time especially depending on which
project I'm working in with the time can
be some sort of investigative things
like looking at aggregate statistics on
problem logs for instance and seeing
what people have been doing and how how
the modifications that we've been
testing out have been affecting that and
and and what if well and you you don't
typically work here I mean you work here
typically in the office where do you
work from yeah normally I'm I work
remotely from New Jersey and I worked
most of the time in the co-working
spaces over there but communicate with
people here through our internal company
taught and through video chat and things
like that
what have you found has been kind of the
the puts and takes of that working
Grimaldi I mean it's nice because you
have sort of a lot of freedom with your
time and where you want to work if I
feel like people bothering you asking to
videotape you nice isolated time and
working at different times on is
actually kind of cool because you get an
uninterrupted block of time every
morning to work in but you lose a lot of
that sort of face to face interaction
that you go with people that's really I
mean we have such great people here that
it's it's really a wonderful interaction
that you ever seeing those sort of
casual conversations so that overall
working out yeah it's working out it's
it's a lot of fun I saw guys interact
with people they base those from here so
yeah and what were you doing before Khan
Academy I was a grad student and briefly
a postdoc at Stanford I
I did my PhD in biochemistry there I did
a lot of sort of work with data analysis
and especially analysis of biological
microscopy images and sort of that
bridge the gap between doing a lot of
more sciency side of data science but
then also programming and statistics and
what made you come here I mean you know
that sounds like you could have been a
professor of biochemistry someplace yeah
well well two things so one I sort of
one thing that I really liked about
science and especially the data analysis
was like getting my hands dirty with the
data in experiments and being able to do
things on a day to day basis I'm not
just like think or talk about them and I
realized that the further you go down
that academic career path the more it's
it becomes abstract and further
disconnected from the doing and I really
liked the doing aspect of things and
actually a friend of mine who is a huge
fan of Khan Academy saw that there were
job openings here and they were posting
anything oh you should totally apply for
this this would be great it would be
perfect for you you'd love this so
that's how I found out about coming how
do mean yeah and and what's you know
what's the experience been like as
what's been surprising to you um and
just I mean I was expecting that there
would be great people here to work with
but I'm just constantly surprised by how
wonderful and varied and just great
people there are to work with here but
continues to surprise me every day how
how awesome if you believe her yeah it
surprises me especially considering
where we started we've been averaging on
who is that guy we've been averaging
we've been we've been averaging up for
sure and what are you excited about I'm
super excited since we just finished the
worm storm finals I'm super excited
about learning for those who don't know
because people all over the planet will
be oh right yeah so learn storm is a is
a pilot Bay Area math competition that
we started that that the idea is to is
not just to compete with math but like
learn and grow new things and get
excited about learning new things and
about
realizing that you can that you can
learn anything and so we had this hugely
successful pilot competition on the bear
and I'm really excited about seeing
where that goes next and how many people
we can get excited yeah you've got a
huge role in it and we just had our kind
of as you mentioned it wasn't about just
kind of a classic math competition it
was celebrating grit and hustle and
perseverance and we just had our
celebration and you played a big role in
that so yeah it was it was great fun and
it was wonderful to see all of the all
of the students there who were just so
excited about math and about learning
which was which was wonderful to see
yeah no no same year well I think I
speak for a whole team it's been been a
huge pleasure to work with you and I
can't wait to see where things go from
here
absolutely it's been a grateful you're
working here so far